1 minute 1 minute 1 minute
one so we are at the bungu site this is
the hungu itself and we will have bab G
and
the owner of this one of the owners of
this Buu explained this to us
now
so so bab G just can we can you I mean
for this you just quickly explain what
the bungu itself is technically so that
you know it's a good introduction to the
whole video very brief one how it drains
the water and what it does okay Buu is a
very simple technology where whatever
the water is getting locked on the STP
soil we inject it in the underground
take it to the region where the water
density is higher than the top water
density water loing water density and
release of water so the land get water
logging free as well as same underground
water which have injected earlier lift
it back do the winter irrigation this
simple okay so this is one bongu yeah so
the B the injection of the water happens
through that Central bore and what we
see around it is for the water get to
get filtered before it gets injected
perfect
huhu or or or
[Music]
speech
B basically he's she's talking of water
logging and water injection process
she's staining at at least this amount
of water comes in the initial period
then it comes up with this level of
initial as the monsoon progress Monsoon
progress and it gets refill three or
four times so so much of water goes
inside and the catchment area for this
bungu is catchment area of this bungu
still the Revol channel so it is more
than 20 acres okay more than 20 acres
land okay and this 20 acres land is
collectively owned by the seven b seven
no irrigation is taking place for 50 ACR
50 V of 20 acres of land yeah 50 V seven
women together all all below poverty
line Omen okay okay and this is the
first time they're doing this igation
earlier they are going for the migration
work now this time they're doing last
whenever they got they go for the
Iration okay so AB
your
speech
IGN speech speech for speech
speeech
speech
so they have a alternative
system every seventh day you get the
your turn so whatever the crop they have
decided based upon that they decide upon
the irrigation process and also ter of
the irrigation duration of the
irrigation then one by one by one go 7
you get the once second but they all
discuss that and collectively
AR
everyone sit together and decide upon it
[Music]
okay she thinks so much of water if you
can give us more machine we can irrigate
so much of land over here there's so
much of potential over
here
okay so this year this is uh how many
years since they've been
using fourth year running this is the
fourth year this is the fourth year what
is the key difference for them before
and
afteru okay before Buu there was no
income level for them they're migrating
now he has not only Buu has done she is
also irating as well as she got two
animals animal
as animal as Buffalo she got and she got
another two B so four animals here she
got that's a huge income for each animal
is at Le 50,000 okay and and what are
the different crops they are now going
in this 20 acres can she list that out
for us what are
theop
she's talking of wheat
Castor cumin isub sua grass and wheat
okay okay total seven CR okay so quickly
if you can add in these details there's
one diesel engine and a pump here that
extracts the water how many HP is this
diesel engine 8 HP 8 HP and this pump so
around how much diesel is used for all
the pumping in a season in one season
approximately approximately cost us
20,000 to
35,000 the diesel diesel cost diesel
cost so that's how many liters are uh
depending on divide by 50 45 something
like that okay that's it okay for one
season for around 20 acres for for 20
acres yeah okay okay thanks
bip